[Music]
your family's here tonight how exciting
is that it's so fun it is fun I get to
while I collaborated woohoo about two
years ago so I'm back here again this
time just to kind of celebrate with
zendaya and the team I also have to ask
you about your BFF miss Kylie Jenner a
new mom what's been the biggest change
that you've seen in her since she gave
birth to stormy I think that whenever
someone has a child no matter who it is
there's always growth and there's always
things to be learned so I think it's
just childbirth and just becoming a
parent it's a beautiful thing she said
that when she told you you said we're
having a baby together
how have you been instrumental it's so
far I think no matter what your best
friend is it's important to be there for
them and be supportive and obviously you
want to help guide them in whatever
decision they make because everyone is
their own person they make their own
decision it's just your job to be there
as a friend to be supportive so I want
to see a reality show you hurt the baby
any chance that we could see that
another another season of life of Kylie
um looks like yes no it's not a yes I
would love that but it's also you have
to find the happy medium of keeping your
private life private
we'll see are you dating anyone huh
myself I'm so focused on being the best
person that I can be I'm not really
worried about it of course I date and I
have fun but when it comes to being
serious it's not really right now
Travis have any friends if he does let
me know Kylie has collaborated with her
sisters on some beauty lines one is the
Jordan Kylie collaboration gonna happen
[Music]
[Applause]